la policía en citó miss ucrania central
responde a una alerta de bomba donde un
electrón hemos recibido un correo
diciendo que han colocado bombas en
todos los centros educativos y
comerciales en la ciudad son una
costumbre si ella suena un poco hastiada
es porque es la undécima alerta que
reciben en lo que va del año solamente
en esta ciudad la policía ucraniana ha
tenido que revisar a nivel nacional más
de tres mil sitios para bombas en las
primeras tres semanas del 2022 todas
falsas alarmas
las autoridades culpan a rusia
esto es un elemento de una guerra
híbrida crean caos e incertidumbre y un
constante estado de estrés para que los
colegios enseñen a la distancia y los
negocios cierran
robots y business las escuelas en
algunas ciudades han estado cerradas
durante semanas debido a alertas de
bomba está intenta evitarlo grupo
julieta hemos creado un grupo que reúne
a padres y empleados de la escuela para
verificar estas amenazas junto a la
policía hicimos todo de manera eficiente
y rápida sin evacuar a los alumnos
pero siempre es una llamada difícil a
pesar de que nunca han encontrado bombas
el servicio de seguridad de ucrania
vaticinó que recientemente atrapó una
pandilla patrocinada por rusos en
zhytomyr
el grupo planeaba una serie de ataques
armados en nuestra región uno de los
miembros es un ciudadano ruso
encontramos municiones armas de fuego
dispositivos explosivos y también
computadoras y dispositivos de
almacenamiento de información que
contienen pruebas de los delitos que
planean
los analistas de defensa de ucrania
creen que es más probable que rusos
perpetren ataques armados dirigidos a
desestabilizar el país que cometan una
invasión a gran escala